all right so I am really excited to be
here I love the city of Chicago I did
just recently moved to the cornfields
from San Francisco but I used to live in
hyde park for many years and it was a
great it was a great place to live for
me personally and I'm excited to be here
because it's really important that
Chicago be part of this pi data thing I
went to PI data a couple years ago in
San Francisco and some of what i did
there will actually be a bit tied to
what i'm going to talk about today so
you're gonna have talks later today on
things like machine learning at scale
but i'm not going to talk about that i'm
going to talk about human learning which
as a professor is a little closer to
what I care about and I am a brand new
professor right I actually this was my
first week as a professor here in
Illinois so I apologize if I'm a little
sleepy right so I do a lot of things I
have various modeling and simulation
projects and you know everything's
really computationally don't do any
experiments but I'm not going to talk
about any of those all right I'm going
to talk about some of the things I do
for fun and the things I've contributed
to and also things that have contributed
to me primarily right so I'm going to
talk about something called the hacker
within something many of you probably
heard of software carpentry spin-off
called lab carpentry for professors who
are setting up their research labs I'm
going to talk a little bit about books
that are important and helpful and talk
very briefly about my research group and
about some work that we did at the
berkeley institute for data science
which I just left about a month ago but
first let me talk about my first
experience here at PI data in San
Francisco has invited a few years ago to
be part of a satellite experience at PI
data it was targeted at middle school
girls right and the idea behind this was
that middle school girls have just as
much hunger for data-intensive workflows
we do and so a really rock star group of
women were invited to PI data I believe
on the num focus docket to teach them
how to scrape the web and how to use
pandas to analyze a little bit of
Instagram data and it was a total blast
and I loved it and I had been teaching
adults for quite a long time but this
this was really awesome and it gave me a
glimpse into the future and that glimpse
was really positive and terrifying at
the same time because what it showed me
was that every single one of these girls
had hundreds thousands of colleagues
their age who also wanted to learn this
stuff and we are not ready at all to
teach them so I'm going to talk a little
bit about how hard it is to scale up
human learning based on some experiences
have had and and the problem that I see
and the problem that I see right now is
that the world today as you all well no
and I'm not going to reiterate it for
you because here at the forefront of it
that the world is extremely data
intensive and computational right now
every interaction that you have is
mediated with some element of
computation and data spinning around us
at all times and we as humans at all
ages little couples college students
emeritus professors everyone is clearing
to learn how to live in it properly and
to make use of it and so I'd like to
talk to you a little bit about what I
think that means for us but I think you
already know so let's do a little
experiment those of you who are sitting
in front of your laptops please take a
moment away from your github issues and
navigate to this URL Poli vcom / Katie
huff that's my name those of you with
Pokemon go machines you can also
navigate there with your pocket computer
and answer this question because I don't
need to tell you what sorry
I apologize camera people that I've just
ja sold I don't need to tell you you
guys already know where kinds of skills
are necessary in a data to data
intensive computational world what kinds
of skills were maybe not yet teaching
self-directed learning see now it's a
word cloud so it's going to look a
little funky if there's more than one
word sorry alright mathematical thinking
rigor computational rigor no doubt SQL
we're going to need some learning
thinking coding all this stuff
communication logic software skills
that's right Python y'all are getting
the hang of this statistics
architectures charts books etc etc right
it starts to get really serious there's
a whole lot of stuff if you focus on the
things that we're not teaching you know
there are some interesting community
issues around here I see someone's put
oh no trolling and cruel bad creatures
we're being serious here that's funny
empathy is one of them right that's an
interesting contribution statistics is
really popular I don't love word clouds
but in this in this context it's kind of
fun to see statistics grow so large yeah
they need all of these skills you know
and we're not necessarily teaching
software very well at the elementary
school level will not we're not
necessarily teaching how to set up an
API call from your favorite database
right you know grade school students
don't necessarily need to know how to
use an API key but should high school
students maybe start to learn that
information like probably right as soon
as they start scraping the web in their
college classes they should have done so
before and are they doing enough web
scraping in their college classes maybe
not right and do emeritus professors
also need to learn some of this stuff
yeah absolutely now beyond academia I
know that many of you are in actual
companies right what does this mean for
training right when's the last time you
tried to hire someone with all these
skills how hard is that how much you
have to offer them to show up to your
company
training people is a problem that we all
face not just me as a professor I may be
more fault for some of the failures in
training as part of the press aureate
now but ultimately all of these things
really need to need to be part of it
hacking visualization I love your
answers I think these are all accurate
how do you fit them into the curriculum
there's no more room anyway so I asked a
couple of other audiences what they
thought I asked sorry this is super
teenie let's see if I can make it bigger
yeah that's the spirit um so I asked the
pie hpc conference this question in the
context of HP see if we want hpc skills
you know some of them don't know how to
spell math but that's cool um but it's a
great set of answers to this really
focused on HP see I asked a small group
of other data driven people and they
came up with practically the same
answers that you did so other data
scientists agree with this group of data
scientists we need statistics we need
pattern recognition we need math we need
distributed computing and machines right
what are we going to teach that so I'm
going to talk to you about a couple of
things that I do that are helping a
little bit i'm going to talk about a
couple of things that i've seen other
people do that are helping me and then
i'm going to talk about what you need to
do I have a task for all of you so
there's this organization is called the
hacker within its a peer-led
organization for scientific computing
best practices and when I was a graduate
student I found I needed all of these
skills to suddenly do research without
any without any training at all i needed
to be a computational nuclear engineer
right i had the nuclear engineering part
but I was definitely expected to learn
all the computing myself thankfully I
had a really good advisor who encouraged
us to go sit together and learn it not
alone but together with each other and
he's great he's one of the most
interesting people and I love him and he
encouraged us to start this organization
called the hacker within where we would
find the hugger within ourselves right
hacking skills and we could sit together
with other grad students who were
struggling with stuff this is what it
looks like when the hacker birthing gets
together
just a bunch of people with laptops
talking about you know skills in the
shell right it started at Wisconsin
where I went to graduate school yeah
that's right badgers and then I moved to
Berkeley and I took it there and the
University of Melbourne tried to
institute it but that actually didn't
work out very well they started doing
our own thing which involved more beer
I'm not even kidding I'm not kidding at
all um Michigan State tried it and it
was really great but there was a
graduate student who was really pumped
about it but became became significantly
under she didn't have enough labor hours
available to her to stand it up and then
a staff person tried to stand it up and
people don't want to follow a staff
person into something that's supposed to
be a peer let organization so that
didn't work either at Yale it was
another enthusiastic but overworked
graduate student didn't work there at
the Swinburne institute of technology
science and technology in melbourne
australia they had had experience with
the giver soup melbourne and they
decided to start it and it worked and
also at the University of Illinois
before I got there a student from the
University of Wisconsin hacker within
groups started there so this group is
starting up all over the place there's
now one at UC Davis it's going well it's
not on this slide yet because it's only
been like one semester but I believe
that they will survive and I think it's
it works because there's a community
around it and we were able to teach each
other important skills around a table of
peers and there's no real hierarchy
people speak when they want to speak and
give talks about stuff they're excited
about and no one's top-down deciding
what the topics should be and if you
show up to the meeting you get to push
to the github account you know it's
really maximization of permissions and
there's sometimes beer which is helpful
this is sort of what it looks like when
people get together with the hacker thin
and ideally that kind of camaraderie
creates a peer driven learning and
teaching and I encourage you to think
about what that would look like in your
sation you know could you have a
situation where you bring together all
the mixed skill levels in your company
or your new startup or your research
group that could allow people to teach
each other things that they know because
even if in mixed skill levels you know
someone who seems to have a very high
skill level in computing in general may
lack other kinds of skills so people
would lower skill levels can try to try
to normalize that by teaching even the
people with higher skill levels and
other things so it also you know people
love to teach each other you know I
found that it really appeals to people's
desire to show off what they know which
is you know we're rarely rewarded for
just knowing these kinds of
computational data analysis skills until
there's a plot right until there's a
decision made based on that data but
it's also really useful to say you know
hey I can make your workflow more
efficient and you it's very rewarding so
you know that kind of stuff is really
good we have a lot of topics this is an
example set of the topics from last year
at Berkeley you know it's Python for
plotting time series matplotlib handling
visualization geospatial data
metaprogramming lay tech you know stuff
like that right and it goes on and on we
had some really impressive people at
Berkeley's that were often really
excited to show off their skills you
know we had but you know Matthias was
teaching advanced Python right like
where do you get that you know I Python
developers teaching you how to use
ipython is pretty nice I'll move on from
this but so the hacker would then is the
thing that you should think about when
you think about what kinds of models
have worked in other places you should
think about what's failed maybe learn
from learn from our mistakes don't let a
single person alone who's already
overworked set up the whole peer-to-peer
training program on their own be with
them help them it takes more than one
person because otherwise it will
flounder and let it be peer-to-peer so
people don't feel like they're being
taught that
like they're having a conversation
instead what else is helping so that
within doesn't scale very well to remove
about 30 people and maybe to the number
of chapters that exist which is now like
five that's not for carbon two does
scale how many of you have heard of
cipher carpentry yeah I keep your hands
up if you are a software carpentry
instructor that's right we've got a
couple of them Elizabeth raise your hand
alright so software carpentry is amazing
it's another num focus funded
organization and it has been scaling
really well it takes this sort of
peer-to-peer learning and teaching model
way to its limit basically what it is
here's its logo it's under the num focus
umbrella it has now its own foundation
and it has an elected steering committee
and an advisory council made up of all
the people that we we think of as
important in scientific computing
education right now frankly and it's
doing really well and they're the
tagline is that we make researchers in
science engineering medicine more
productive by teaching them basic skills
for scientific computing right anyone
who's gone through the software
carpentry program is going to be
slightly more hireable at your company's
slightly more attractive as a
collaborator on your open source project
slightly more trained to merge or pull
request right and this is what it looks
like it's a lot like the hacker within
but more orderly if they're typically
these two days of workshops scientists
teach scientists instructors or
volunteers the materials are all open
source we no longer teach knows actually
just changed it to PI test last week but
this slide is old sorry we teach bash in
order to teach people to automate tasks
we teach Python to teach them to build
modular code we teach get so that they
will track and share their work as
scientist this is actually very rare we
teach SQL to manage data we used to
teach knows but as of like a couple
weeks ago we now to teach pi test
because notes is no longer being
maintained
and to teach people to test their code
and program defensively are there about
a million other packages we'd like to
teach scientists absolutely I did most
of you author one yes but this is what
we're teaching so that people can get
the basics of how to appropriately
design software um there are workshops
everywhere all over the world it's
pretty amazing the number of workshops
that are involved here as of about May
of this year we taught 500 people and I
mean we taught 16,000 people and had run
500 workshops this is because we have a
team of volunteers and they're all over
the place sorry this is harder when it's
zoomed in lots and lots of instructors
and who are the instructors there people
you know open source developers
scientific programmers people in
startups who used to be postdocs
somewhere used to be graduate students
somewhere there are people like skipper
there you know people in this audience
and you know I think frankly the reason
they do it is partly for the community I
don't just think that so I used to serve
on the steering committee as chairs
during committee first one and we asked
the instructors why they do it in this
these answers came out community they
like to travel so these workshops happen
in a lot of different places and
sometimes you get the excuse to go to
Italy and good teach one they often want
teaching experience because teaching is
a skill that is needed in the world and
some people teach in order to learn all
right but finally I think there's a
great deal of sense need the more
collaborations that you're involved in
that have a different set of skills that
then you have maybe a diverse set of
stacks that people work with maybe some
people work with mercurial and some
people work with get some people work
with Python some people worth worth are
and you have all in one research group
or 11 team trying to get something done
you know
you sense this need that everyone needs
a lot of like a basic starting block off
of which to work and you know it's going
really well okay said there's a ton of
instructors trained and a ton of
workshops that have been run we've been
running workshops of various sizes all
the way up to 150 people at once but
even this doesn't scale right if you're
constrained to a room of 140 people and
it takes three worker workshop it takes
three instructors to train people it can
only scale to the level of that it's
currently scaling and I'm telling you it
is that the bleeding edge of what it is
capable of scaling to if it's scaled any
faster it would it would not work you
know and data carpentry is another
similar organization or sister
organizations that that's at the
beginning of that scaling you know and
those challenges are really serious so
so what have we learned from the scaling
um you know you can create a bottom-up
grassroots organization of people like
you to teach other people the things
they need to know to be effective at
using data and computers for their
research for decision-making for data
science but we still need more and I'll
tell you some things that have been
helping in addition to these two
organizations you've probably heard of
some of them bind it wow this is like
really zoomed in so there's something
called my binder the Jeff Jeremy Freeman
he's a neuro scientist it's a
exceptional open source project that
just rent runs a server a cloud service
for rendering interactive ipython
notebooks on the browser so this means
that you can run a Jupiter notebook and
change the variables and re-execute the
cells without ever installing ipython on
your computer what does this mean for
education any ideas what's the biggest
barrier to teaching a workshop it's
stalling the software that first hour is
still painful even with Python even with
Conda even with our new universe of
slightly well managed packages the
problem is that just getting someone to
open a terminal
and install something or open a terminal
and type Jupiter notebook that is a
barrier right to getting them to program
and getting them to play with a model
getting them to see what the data will
do and this i have used in the last week
in my class my traditional nuclear
engineering class i'm teaching a
classroom of 30 students how to do some
nuclear engineering right and i can get
them to try different things with a
model andrey plot the plot with a
different value for the for the
independent variable because i don't
have to ask them to install anything
they can just open their browser change
the variable press shift enter and it's
happening so thank you to jeremy freeman
for this service unfortunately is also
running on their dime so you have to
deploy it on your own servers if you
want it to run consistently because
sometimes it's down just due to demand
there's only called lab carpentry and
there's made up of a bunch of people who
were involved with software carpentry
who are becoming researchers and leaders
in their labs on their own and it's been
really useful to me as a brand new
professor and I think it would be
frankly very useful to teams in the data
science world because it has some hints
on how to organize your lab we have a
blog where we're answering questions
mostly targeted at people in the tenure
track but certainly of interest of
people running open-source development
groups because a lot of its going to be
about how to you know deal with
community and there are some workshops
on how to train but these organization
blueprints are like templates for a
website that has a code of conduct for
your lab and has guides for how to start
things and is an easy documentable
resource alright so there's also a neat
book that John De Niro wrote that's like
a nice interactive online book that was
designed for the undergraduates at
Berkeley who are taking their data
science course right and I strongly
encourage you guys to check it out it's
open source is free and you can comment
on it with hypothesis or whatever it is
you like if your is that what it's
called um you can there's like metadata
you're allowed to make little comments
back to John Janeiro through this
interface it's a nice good book and it
is a really good introduction to data
science there are other introductions to
data science that some of you have
written Andres Mueller just is about to
come out with this rally book oh so this
book is called it's for data science 8
and so it's called the foundations of
data science which is the same name is a
class at Berkeley so you can get there
if you go to my and i'll show you whoops
we're all there we go I'll give you the
link to this this at the end of the talk
which is very soon I also wrote a book I
was concerned that my graduate students
would not be ready to work with me all
right so let's get to the reality of the
situation this is my need this is my
need that I'm describing to you I I need
graduate students who are going to push
and pull to a git repo ASAP and I need
those people to be trained in sufficient
testing that they're not going to have
to have their papers retracted and I
need them to be capable of interacting
kindly with each other on github and my
friend Anthony and I wrote this book
it's great O'Reilly book strongly
recommend it it covers a lot of these
features you know I'm sorry it shows you
an introduction the command line and
blast off with Python it shows your
containers classes and objects all
introduction to python it talks about
analysis visualization regular
expressions it's intended for people in
the STEM disciplines in particular like
the physical sciences but you can see a
lot of these things are useful for
everyone because we're all starting at
the same starting block in the universe
of computing later parts are about
validation and verification effectively
building pipelines version controlling
debugging and testing and documentation
publication in collaboration we talked
about git github talk about sphinx and
how to license your code if you want it
to be open source there's a bunch of
runnable ipython notebooks online that
have been
the tested at simon fraser university by
tiffany timbers and you can find those
at physics dash codes / seminar so if
you're curious and this is what they
look like here's the testing one so you
can run them you can even run them in my
binder if you want also there's new
curriculum out there and universities
are trying to scale it so book scale
okay book scale because you know you can
write them and anyone can buy them and
now we're scaling a little better right
books are great and ideally universities
will take that and teach people on mass
right and I would love to say that that
seems to be working but they are
overwhelmed from my experience watching
universities from the inside set up
these data science programs the demand
is enormous all right I cannot stress
this enough the number of undergraduates
who come in thinking you know what I'm
going to come out of this a data
scientist it's terrifying Berkeley has a
solution where they merge data science
into core curricula so you can come out
with like a date of science minor and
certain some professors are equipped to
teach such a class and some professors
are not and the to the credit of
Berkeley they've been identifying the
professors in the domains who are
capable of doing that and encouraging
them to introduce computational modules
that fit within the curriculum plan that
they have for these undergraduates so
Berkeley if you've got curriculum that's
you know running undergraduates through
a pipeline like this like now you're
starting to really scale you've got
state level support for these
universities you know and you can go
further at Illinois there's a MOOC for
data science master's programs like 32
credits I don't know if it's working but
I know that it's popular all right I
don't know what the people who come out
of the end of it are like I've not met
any of them I don't know if they're
getting hired or if they have the kinds
of skills that they need but tons of
people are interested in this and so you
know the question is is it enough and I
will argue to you in my last two minutes
here that it's not
right and I will tell you why so frankly
I learned these skills personally from
people like you I and Jake Vander Plaats
I was on a panel with him and he said
the same exact thing we were like
mirroring each other I learned these
skills from the Society of open source
the university if you will of open
source I learned it from making pull
requests and getting those pull requests
rejected right so this is what I leave
you with right in this universe where
we've got a data intensive computational
world that people are not prepared for
but they want to be prepared we all have
to teach each other we have to teach
people who are younger than us we have
to teach people who are older than us we
have to teach people who are around us
and we all have to do it in our
companies in our universities we have to
do it in our faculty meetings it turns
out and we have to do it all the time
that's the only thing that's going to
scale right you go all understand
parallelization let's parallel eyes this
right and what I suggest you out sorry
someone wants to take a picture I will
allow it because you have invited me
here to speak all right so i encourage
you then to take some advice from Claude
Steele who is a social scientist who
studies and implicit bias in our
universe one should lower the barrier to
entry never lower the standards because
that's insulting and the way to do that
in the University of open source I have
some suggestions give your new
developers some instructions document
your code make the list host non-private
make sure that the expectations for
every pull requests are defined clearly
like in a contribution CMD document
github will just render it beautifully
every time they try to make a pull
request make sure that all the issues
that would be easy for new person are
labeled
hanging fruit get those people on board
make sure that the permissions are given
generously because people respond to
respect and make sure that it's clear
how issues are accepted in your project
things that are a little harder you
could run a sprint where you invite
people to come and work on your code but
what you have to do is make sure that
it's easy to build your code from source
by anyone you might appoint ambassador
to new users right that has worked in
the past for other for open source
projects that I'm aware of the that
person reaches out when someone seems
like a brand new user or brand new
possible developer mentoring those
people directly with that ambassador and
maybe even hosting a conference of new
users can get those people on board
faster so those are my suggestions for
you to go out and teach all the time
incorporate it into your open source
workflow and be the professor's of your
open source university because that's
what's really going to teach people
thank you